no one is thinking about the broader
strategic picture or the common good
they're all just thinking about
themselves summed up perfectly by joy
behar on the view who said you know the
worst part of this whole ukraine issue
what's going to happen to my roman
holiday
estimates are 50 000 ukrainians will be
dead or wounded yeah and that this is
going to start a humanitarian crisis a
refugee crisis in europe we're talking
about five million people
that that are going to be displaced yeah
i mean
it's it's heartbreaking to hear what is
going to happen yeah well i'm scared of
what's going to happen in in western
europe too yeah you know you just you
plan a trip you want to go there i want
to go to italy for four years i haven't
been able to make it because of
of uh the pandemic and now this you know
it's like who's gonna what's gonna
happen there
when when joy bahar started saying this
i thought it was the setup to a joke
you know yeah and you know the real
problem is i i don't get to stay at my
tuscan villa this summer and i didn't
even get to last year either
but it wasn't she was dead she was 100
serious
and this is instructive this is how
our elites
think
i'm not just talking about the elites in
government i'm talking about the elites
in government media like joy behar the
elites in private industry
they're not thinking about
the national good they're not even
thinking about the global humanitarian
good they're just thinking about numero
uno
you know you know gosh this really
teaches me about suffering because i i
feel bad for those children being
shelled in kiev right now but but i
might not even get to go to the uffizi
this summer
can you you know it's suffering right
hey ain't that ain't that just the way
suffering works
hold up glad you like that clip you got
to ring the bell please i would
appreciate that you ring the bell you'll
get notifications you should also head
on over to apple podcast spotify stitch
your google play wherever you get your
audio podcasts type in the michael
knowles show subscribe leave a five star
review if you wouldn't mind we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you